so love them or hate them these
characters definitely leave you thinking
these are 15 Heroes who fell far enough
to become the villain Wanda maximoff
started out as a threat to the Avengers
But ultimately joined them to take down
Ultron being a hero is hard enough
especially when you keep losing people
like she lost her brother and then her
lover One Division explores her grief by
having her Force an entire town to act
out her sitcom fantasy but it was Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
where her true villainy became clearest
this is me
being
reasonable we sometimes do the worst
things for our loved ones something this
next person knows all too well how far
would you be willing to go to keep your
family safe Walter White was willing to
leave his low-paying job as a chemistry
teacher to start raking in the cash
selling some pretty life-running drugs
all to make sure his family would be
okay after he passed away and like it
cost him the love of his family anyway
but considering how selfish he is by the
end of the series I am not in danger
Skyler I am the danger you can only
really feel bad for the well-intentioned
man he used to be sort of like a certain
former Jedi Master Anakin Skywalker was
supposed to be the chosen one he became
a Jedi and helped keep the Galaxy safe
during the Clone Wars but with Palpatine
in his ear encouraging Anakin to embrace
the dark side of the force good is a
point of view anyway it became a little
inevitable that he'd complete his
transformation into Sith Lord dark Vader
just as inevitable as it is for you to
hit that subscribe button so maybe do
that now while we're moving on to
discussing another figure manipulated by
a big dark shadowy figure if you had the
ability to kill someone from a distance
would you do it light gains the ability
by finding the Death Note a book that
spells the end for anyone who has their
name written in it and although he
swears to use it only to rid the world
of evil he quickly gets swept up in the
power and becomes the very sort of
villain he set out to defeat it's not
enough this world is still rotten and
speaking of Heroes who became the type
of villain he hunted small packages
don't always mean good things like
Daenerys Targaryen or Scrappy do the
latter of whom was introduced as
Scooby's pint-sized nephew in the 70s
and came to be known as one of the most
hated fictional characters of all time
James Gunn decided to play on this image
by making him the villain of Scooby-Doo
the movie introducing him as a former
member of Mystery Inc who was kicked out
for being annoying that little egomaniac
had flipped his lid and so he sought
Revenge by taking over Spooky Island
Daenerys was a clear fave for succession
of the Iron Throne she tried to be just
listen to advice and best of all she had
dragons I mean how cool is that but
after the battle of King's Landing
Daenerys totally snaps and gives in to
the dreaded Targaryen Madness that
plagued many of her ancestors taking out
hundreds of innocent people while on the
back of her Dragon it was necessary many
of us were just as disappointed by this
as people of Gotham were by our next
entry Harvey Dent was supposed to save
Gotham you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain as district attorney he was able
to fight crime in a way that even Batman
couldn't but after losing his girlfriend
to Mobsters who simultaneously left him
with scars on one hand of his face
Gotham's White Knight became two-faced a
Vengeance driven madman who uses the
flip of a coin to decide how to get back
at the Mobsters who had done this to him
you had one job Harvey but then again so
did this next person as head of the
white Council Saruman was supposed to
protect Middle Earth from the Dark Lord
but over time he grew jealous of the
amount of power the dark lord had
against the power of mortal
there can be no Victory so when Gandalf
tells him where to find the One Ring
Saruman decides to claim it for himself
or else join the Dark Lord and serve by
his side in doing so Saruman betrays the
white Council similar to how this next
person betrays the X-Men Jean Gray has
always been like the most powerful
member of the X-Men her telekinetic
Powers gave even Professor Xavier a run
for his money and the worst part is that
she isn't always able to keep them under
control when it comes people get hurt
when she loses control she becomes
bonded with an ancient destructive force
known as the Phoenix Force turning her
into the villainous dark Phoenix at
which point she takes out mystique and
even destroys an entire planet she may
not want to be doing any of this but
that only makes her more like our next
entry on the list Michael Corleone never
wanted anything to do with the family
business even after he became the god
father he still tried to turn it all
around into a legitimate business and
even set up a charitable Foundation but
his need for revenge and his ruthless
approach to getting it sort of muddies
that a bit things may get tough with the
move we're trying in the end his violent
life makes him far from a heroic figure
like a certain super-powered teenager
who knows something about family being a
bad influence absolute power corrupts
absolutely look at Andrew Detmer he
started out pretty low on the social
ladder but when he stumbles across a
mysterious Crystal that grants him
superpowers he finds himself with a new
lease on life but this isn't the
superhero origin you would think instead
Andrew views himself as an apex predator
lion does not feel guilty when it kills
of gazelle using his powers to get
revenge against those who hurt him and
if this list proves anything it's that
Revenge can be a dangerous motivator
Eric lentra may have good reason to
believe he needs to to protect himself
like he was experimenting on while at
Auschwitz before going on to become
friends with Charles Xavier and even
helping him to gather the first X-Men
excuse me I'm Eric Lynch Xavier But Eric
never could get over his past and
although it broke Xavier's heart to see
him go they went their separate ways as
Eric sought Revenge sort of like a
certain prom queen poor Carrie White
like Andrew Detmer she was bullied a lot
in school and when she went to prom her
bullies rigged the election for prom
queen just to dump Pig's blood over her
in front of everyone but what they
didn't see coming was Carrie's
telekinetic Powers which similar to Jean
Gray she couldn't always control carries
got her revenge whether they'd made fun
of her or not similar to how this next
guy turned against his best friend you
probably know Lex Luthor as Superman's
rival but did you know that he and Clark
used to be friends yeah according to
Smallville they got along great except
for the fact that when Lex discovered
that Clark was a super-powered alien he
wanted to use him to his benefit my
intellect your powers and speaking of
villains who have a complicated
relationship with their hero sometimes
all it takes is one bad day am I right
and Arthur Flex had several like his
work as a clown became a nightmare after
he was beaten on the job his dream of
being a stand-up comedian wasn't working
out and to make matters worse the city
defunded the one Lifeline he had in his
mental health treatment ain't got
nothing left to lose and so Arthur
became the Joker inciting chaos and
encouraging others to do the same
so which of these Heroes turned villains
is your favorite and are there any other
characters we forgot to mention we're
sure there's a lot we'd love to hear
your thoughts so make sure to let us
know in the comment section below